françois michel lambert bonjour bonjour
à ses fins merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin alors on le disait
un la situation sanitaire
mais elle se dégrade en france avec la
propagation du variant delta et qu'est
ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui du
gouvernement selon vous est-ce qu'il
faut très vite mettre de nouvelles
restrictions les restrictions je crois
que ont suivi beaucoup vous venez juste
d'annoncer la réouverture des boîtes de
nuit demain et pas dans la même case
iman même phase on me parlait de mettre
en place des restrictions les
restrictions c'est celle qui nous
empêche de vivre pleinement donc moi je
pense que nous devons aller plus vite
sur la vaccination pour ça que nous
avions interviewé d'ailleurs je suis
expert en logistique la france a pris du
retard sur le tarn ils n'arriveront
jamais rattrapés comme dans la lah
la fable du lièvre et la tortue
aujourd'hui le gouvernement doit avec
les partis politiques réussir à donner
une impulsion nouvelle à ce que les
français aillent se faire vacciner
en plus l'offre des vaccins est très
large ce qui sont inquiet sur les mines
les vaccins dits arn peuvent trouver des
solutions dans d'autres vaccins
notamment même dans un vaccin à une
seule injection pour ceux qui ont peur
des piqûres
on va et et nous devons réussir à
changer de niveau et de dimension en
termes de de vaccination en france alors
la vaccination la carte maîtresse dit
également le gouvernement olivier
ferrand et les professionnels de santé
hier ont signé une déclaration commune
dans le pour une vaccination mais
obligatoire mais pour les soigner en
vous y est favorable aussi de pour cette
obligation
ouais je suis toujours favorable à ce
que l'on amène à ce que lorsqu à une
obligation elle soit acceptée
collectivement toc l'année un premier
pas qui est cette déclaration commune
notamment avec les représentants est ce
que ce sont tous les représentants mais
avec les représentants des
professionnels de santé
oui nous devons arriver à ce que les
professions santé soient vaccinés mais
nous ne devons pas sombrer
et on a bien vu que vous êtes plus en
france un seul dirait dans d'autres pays
nous pouvons par rack et notre notre
population nos concitoyens les ligier
jaune en était une démonstration
extrêmement visible extrêmement vive le
respect que nous avons aussi aux
soignants on peut comprendre peut-être
que certains se posent des questions sur
d'autres approches donc le dialogue qui
démarre vraiment trop tard parce que
cette question de faut-il vacciner les
soignants elle date du printemps et on
commence à dialoguer avec les
professionnels de santé
depuis deux semaines et encore peut-être
une seule semaine donc encore une fois
le gouvernement déclenche trop tard ce
qu'il aurait fallu mettre en place moi
j'invite à encore plus de dialogue et je
serai évidemment dans ce qui invite les
soignants à se vacciner mais pas à ceux
qui les imposent
il faut qu'à un moment donné nous
trouvions le chemin pour que eux
acceptent qu'ils comprennent eux ils
font partie de la solution
alors à propos de la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants voyez ce qu'en
dit le président du conseil de l'ordre
des médecins
obliger les soignants à se faire
vacciner cela veut dire que demain il
faudra peut-être obligé d'autres corps
de métiers à se faire vacciner et cela
peut poser la question de la vaccination
obligatoire tout court l'obligation
générale doit être débattu sur le plan
démocratique
elle ne peut pas être simplement
édictées par le pouvoir exécutif
qu'est ce que vous en pensez si on
oblige les soignants à se faire vacciner
c'est finalement tout le monde qui doit
l'être tout à fait opposés en meilleurs
termes que moi je le reconnaître la
question la question et cette obligation
qu'elle est la chaîne d'entraînement
c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui aura après
comme autres obligations qui seront
mises en oeuvre
les banquiers les services publics
diverses et variées tous les agents
d'accueil privé je ne sais peut-être
tous les chauffeurs de bus etc etc
donc aujourd'hui
le dialogue est vraiment qu'au début et
c'est la très bonne critique
j'ai de ce diamant et jeu j'envoie un
message et au nom de liberté cologie
fraternité et dont je suis président mon
parti envoie un message également en
disant nous les politiques nous voulons
participer à la capacité de de réussir
cette acceptation par ceux qui doivent
être vaccinés dans le cadre de leur
mission et en premier lieu par les
soignants et cette défiance de certains
français vis-à-vis du vaccin finalement
vous le comprenez comment cette défiance
des français
j'ai pu lire que les russes ont une
défiance encore plus élevé on le voit
dans nombre de pays a peut-être les
français sont un petit peu plus défiants
que d'autres mais il n'ya pas une
différence notable par contre ce que
l'on voit c'est que les politiques en
général est peut-être en france en
particulier où on a eu le sketch les
masques ne servent à rien on a eu les
sketchs des changements de pied
permanent sur des règles à mettre en
oeuvre
eh bien ils se disent peut-être que dans
ce créneau et nous dirons que finalement
le vaccin ne servait à rien donc on
ferait mieux d'attendre
voilà quand on est clair dans ce que
nous mettons en oeuvre
eh bien je pense que derrière il ya une
réponse claire de la part des citoyens
il n'y a pas vraiment de débat
actuellement là il faut dire mme lam
acronis n'est pas en un mouvement qui
acceptent le débat c'est un mouvement
qui fait semblant qui fait du vertical
on pourrait parler de la convention
citoyenne climat qui est un faux
semblants qui à l'arrivée est
complètement broyé par une pétition
verticale et macro nien et bien dans le
cadre de la vaccination
on retrouve ces ferments de 2 seulement
que débats de ce manque de dialogue tout
ce manque de partage de ce manque de
transparence
et si j'ai un conseil je dirai au
gouvernement il est urgent de changer de
méthode
alors toujours est il que la vaccination
n'est pas encore obligatoire dans ce
contexte
voyez ce que préconise le candidat à la
présidentiel xavier bertrand
je souhaite par contre que l'on
développe beaucoup plus vite le pass
sanitaires et de dire à ceux qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner et pas
seulement les soignants
qu'ils ne peuvent pas nous mettre en
risque s'ils font le choix de ne pas se
faire vacciner alors ils doivent savoir
qu'ils n'auront pas la même liberté que
les autres alors est ce que vous vous
rejoignez cette idée est ce qu'il y a
pas un risque finalement de diviser les
français comme le 2 non st les opposants
ou pas ça ni terre le risque est de
croire que l'on va gagner la bataille
il faut la gagner contre le virus mais
ça risque d'être une victoire à la
pyrrhus je rappelle que la victoire à la
pyrrhus c'est tout le monde a perdu
évidemment les vaincus mais les
vainqueurs ont tellement perdu de
crédibilité que ils ont disparu aussi et
vous venez de le dire
oui il ya cet enjeu majeur de réussir à
gagner contre le virus mais il ya un
enjeu supérieur on sait que la cohésion
de la nation
il ya une cohésion des peuples est
extrêmement importante et monter les uns
contre les autres pour des décennies
parce que c'est des choses qui pour
entraîner pendant des décennies toi tu
t'es pas fait vacciner
toi tu m'a imposé à être vaccinés serait
une catastrophe pour le devenir de ce
qu'est la france
donc je ne rejoins pas xavier bertrand
dans son expression
je souhaite justement le gouvernement
comprenne bien que l'enjeu est double
l'urgence de combattre la maladie et de
nous retrouver une totale liberté
mais l'obligation en politique est
vraiment je le dis politique au sens
profond du terme de garder la cohésion
d'un peuple nous ne pouvons pas fracturé
le peuple et le chemin reste toujours
toujours le dialogue d'ailleurs julien
dépensière l'instant parce que tout le
monde l'a oublié
il y as depuis janvier une convention
citoyenne pour justement créé
l'acceptation de la vaccination
je vous invite à essayer de retrouver
vos inscriptions que sont devenus ces
citoyens tirés au sort qui soi-disant
devait aider à ce que tous ensemble on
accepte la vaccination qu'on comprenne
le sens de la vaccination qu'on trouve
le chemin de la vaccination est bien des
outils de
le gouvernement lance et oublie
complètement parce que il aurait
peut-être eu des réponses qui ne lui
conviennent pas dans sa volonté d'être
extrêmement verticale extrêmement
jupitérienne et de laisser le président
de la république au petit peuple
français il dire ce qui est bien et ce
qui est pas bien c'est pas comme ça
qu'on dirige un peuple c'est pas en
étant j'allais dire dans une posture au
dessus du peuple
on est dans le peur et on voit bien que
cet outil tu aurais pu être très
intéressant a complètement disparu
qu'est devenue la convention citoyenne
pour la vaccination
alors en ce qui concerne l'économie à
présent malgré la pandémie
le nombre de milliardaires français a
encore grimpé en 2021
elle c'est ce que nous révèle le
magazine challenges alors par exemple la
fortune du patron de lvmh bernard
arnault a bondi de 57 % en un an alors
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
c'est vrai que beaucoup de français des
travailleurs s'interrogent eux qui ont
perdu beaucoup pendant la crise est-ce
qu'il ya deux mondes parallèles
finalement oui deux mondes parallèles
qui sont le et aujourd'hui edgar morin
vexé 100 ans edgar morin dans ses
analyses disait quand même assez
extraordinaire
l'homme a créé une science l'économie
des mathématiques c'est probablement là
sciences des mathématiques la plus
avancée
et pourtant c'est la plus arriérée parce
qu'elle est en incapacité de tenir
compte du réel le réel qui est
l'écologie qu'est notre planète le réel
qu'est la sociologie le vivre ensemble
est au big three et là le résultat est
aujourd'hui on est en train d'attacher
et de laisser certains partir avec une
cette science économique s'enrichir
toujours plus sans comprendre que le
réel qui est nous les humains la planète
l'histoire est bien est en train d'être
balayée par
alors excusez nous on a des travaux vous
l'entendez peut-être chez moi j'ai le
soleil de provence à vous voyez et bien
voilà donc nous nous avons et j'espère
que vous en avez aussi à paris et dans
toute la france des travaux à côté donc
un peu de un peu de gêne en tout cas
toujours à propos d'argent
j'aime parler de science et le réel nous
rattrape toujours l'homme après quand
même le virtuel et l'économiste du
virtuel je vous rappelle ce sont des
chiffres eux ni les plantes ni les
animaux de compagnie est sûre ce virtuel
l'homme
il ya beaucoup plus d'attache que sur le
réel le réel c'est le bruit le réel
c'est l'action le réel c'est la nature
le réel c'est malheureusement aussi la
planète qui brûle hélas le l'homme est
en incapacité d'être à la hauteur des
enjeux et j'en appelle à ces
milliardaires qui ont gagné temps et en
argent
ils sont non du virtuel jeux virtuels il
faut qu'ils déversent pour que le réel
soit sauvé le réel ses notations le réel
c'est notre planète
alors vous parlez du climat de la
planète au coeur des débats un ces
derniers jours faute d'un accord
notamment entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat
il n'y aura pas de modification de la
constitution pour le climat c'est une
honte un pour barbara pompili cela reste
symbolique finalement ou un frein à la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
selon vous c'est quoi la constitution
elle est importante est importante mais
elle restait virtuelle qui en a la
constitution qu'on lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique entre
dérèglement climatique et qu'on préserve
la planète
moi c'est ce que je vois d'un
gouvernement qui a fait les jo elle juge
les critiques un tout petit peu là
dessus quand suivi le gouvernement
disant que c'était primordial d qui est
la constitution qu'on allait lutter
contre le crime à moi j'ai pas besoin
d'écrire que j'aime mes enfants je peux
vous décrire que je veux le mieux pour
eux que je le donnerai le maximum pour
eux j'ai pas besoin
on an'a pas toi certains le font fait
notamment à travers un mariage suis pas
de ceux qui est allée devant un acte
notarié un acte plutôt civile pardon ou
un acte notarié pour d'autres d'autres
types pour dire à celle avec qui je suis
que nous partagerons ensemble réel notre
vie donc c'est important mais ce n'est
pas primordial
l'amour est important et même est
primordial pardon l'amour est
primordiale et il n'a pas besoin du
virtuel de l'écriture dans la même façon
sauver la planète
c'est primordial et on n'a pas besoin ça
peut être une bonne chose mais ça ne
doit pas masquer l'écriture dans la
constitution
l'inaction de ce gouvernement et je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
l'apprend d'avancé par rapport à la
juste pour qu'il le climat
ces deux interdits en 2022 les terrasses
chauffées
si avec ça on sauve le climat moi je
signe tout de suite malheureusement ça
n'est pas avec ça on continuera à aller
dans une croissance malheureusement des
gaz à effet de serre et les conséquences
que nous donne ce sondage alors on
arrive au terme de cet entretien mais
peut-être votre réaction sur cette
séquence qui a fait parler d'elle ces
derniers jours sur les réseaux sociaux
et elle concerne gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement
il faisait partie d'un jury en mai
dernier d'un concours d'éloquence des
armées et la vidéo est bien les
ressorties regardez un extrait
personnellement mon héros de l'année
ce n'est pas une ode musk qui m'annonce
que la pelouse sera verte sur mars
moi ça a été charles henry 22 ans qui me
livrer mes soucis à 22 heures ce sont
celles et ceux que je ne connais pas
j'ai compris que c'était charles henry
qui vous livrer vos sushis à 22h du coup
je voulais savoir où est-ce que vous
habitez
à l'humour parfois change de camp mais
les clichés sont toujours dans le même
camp parce que figurez-vous que j'habite
à marseille
alors c'est vrai mais là bas c'est ça
justement peut-être qu'à paris les karim
ils sont dans la rue à marseille sont à
l'université alors l'habitude de
gabriella talent elle a été dénoncée sur
les réseaux notamment
il s'est justifié pour lui la phrase du
candidat ne reflétait pas la réalité
sociale quel est votre avis sur cette
question cette séquence à ce qu'elle est
révélatrice selon vous terrible au cg
dénoncèrent décembre et je crois des
deux de rta dans les quatre colonnes à
l'assemblée nationale et auprès d'autres
médias mais jouer vous m'aviez
interrogées souhaitent retrouver la
bobine en décembre il y avait un dîner
dans lequel tout le monde s'inquiétait
parce que le plaisir la république le
lendemain était positive au coït donc le
dîner s'est révélée c'est le dîner de
tous les jeudis il y à douze hommes
blancs comme moi qui se réunissent à
l'elysée qui décide de la france
regardez la france autour de vous alors
certains diront il ya cette france
particulière mais la france par essence
par l'histoire parce que c'est un pays
complètement différent des autres au
moins complètement différent de tous les
autres européens
ce n'est pas 12 hommes blancs qui se
doivent se réunir tous les jeudis à
l'elysée est donc gabriel attaque qui
fait partie de ceux qui se réunissent
tous les jeudis à déguiser et bien ne
comprend pas que la france elle est
beaucoup plus riche que ça et que nous
avons des karim notamment un qui aurait
pu le sauver pour l'euro c'est karim
benzema et que ce n'est pas charles
henry mais peut-être que charles henry
était le masseur de karim et que
ensemble eh bien on arrive à avoir un
champion parce que karim benzema c'est
sûrement l'un des meilleurs depuis très
longtemps en terme de joueurs de foot en
tant qu'avant-centre donc voilà où les
clichés vous les avez parce que quand
vous vivez ensemble dans un milieu vous
croyez que c'est celui là qui est la
naissance de votre pays eh bien vous ne
comprenez pas votre pays cette
république en marche ne comprends pas ce
pays ces traits plus vite en marche de
12 hommes blancs qui se réunissent tous
les soirs tous les jeudis soir pour
décider de la france
eh bien elle passe à côté de là
france 2 la france profonde c'est ce que
je disais du réel merci à vous françois
michel lambert d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous avez président de liberté
écologie fraternité député des bouches
du rhône